[music]
Good afternoon everyone. Uh thank you so
much for joining on this uh very
important panel discussing about social
acceptance layer. As we know all of
these beautiful technology is actually
integrated into society and today we
have some of the world's experts and
entrepreneurs that are doing it very
very successfully. So I'm going to
please kindly ask you to introduce
yourself and talk a little bit about
your companies and what is the unique
value proposition that you have on the
market.
>> Is it me? Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Um so
first of all I'm not a company. I'm not
from a company. I lead a research
institute and we doing human robotics
since 20 plus years. And um well um what
we doing? We designed robots and uh
specifically at least for today what
happened is that we started
investigating the a topic called human
robot interaction and during this
investigation we discovered they're
super interesting to look at the humans
in the human robot interaction and use
robots to probe how we react to robots
how we create certain bonding and what
it means to interact with the machine
and when the machine can substitute to
the human in the interaction because we
react in the same way. Um, luckily there
are ways to measure this. Um, cognitive
neuroscience tells us how to do it. So,
EG or reaction times, there are gaze
tracking. These are all technologies
that can be used to exactly understand
how we see the robot, how we interact
with the robot and uh maybe in the
future when the robot can in fact engage
with us in a certain way that allows
optimal control, optimal shared action
um and why not optimal companionship.
>> Thank you.
>> Uh yes, I'm Rafael. Uh so this is our
robot and in 5 years each one of you
will have one of have one of our robots
in your private home and that's because
in 3 years we'll be caring for your
elderly parents if you have them. Uh so
we found a very unique approach to
basically start deploying humanoids into
private homes today. In fact, we've been
deploying humanoids in private homes
since 2024.
And we do it and we found a way to do it
very early um through really using
teleoperation not just as sort of this
kind of necessary evil kind of everyone
has to do it but actually using it as a
feature. As you can see the robot has my
face and that's basically whoever
operates the robot that's the face the
robot has. So for the elderly it's not
like for my parents it's not oh this is
my robot this is actually their son
being with them physically and that
makes all the difference. uh we use that
to get into homes to collect the data
the most unique data that's really
interaction of the elderly with the
robot and use that to train the robots
to make them autonomous and um yeah
we'll have 20 robots by the end of the
year people living with them full-time
being cared by the robots and I think
that's sort of uh the way to do it at
least in our hypothesis and at least one
of the people already call it their best
friend so after one week of deployment.
So, I think it's a good start.
>> Um, I'm Morgan Pope. I'm a creative
director at Familiar Machines and Magic.
We are a company founded by Colin Engel,
who was the CEO and founder of iRoot. U
making the little Roombas that roam
around. And, uh, one thing he observed
in 30 years of doing that was how
attached we become to the little things
that move around our house. And, uh, he
wanted to bring them to life in a more
um, powerful emotional way. uh that we
can do now thanks to uh reinforcement
learning for the for leged locomotion
and thanks to uh large language models
for a deeper understanding of human
social environment. So we're making the
first one we're making called it a
familiar it's cute it's little it's
four-legged uh it's going to learn about
you and uh spend time with you and
hopefully just be charming.
>> So hello everybody I'm Monso, founder of
Incendi Tools. That's a company we
founded back in 2021.
So we are creating a robot human wheel
robot mounted on the on the ball which
is make it very convenient in
interaction with people. You can just
bring them somewhere in very easy way.
It's really safe because we are
deploying mainly in hospital with kids
with elderly but also in assisted living
and and such places. Uh our point is uh
we need to build a people facing
humanoid humanoid robots that could be
understandable from by the the the user.
I mean very easy way pointing at
something asking something bringing the
robot somewhere and keeping the a
positive interaction not feeling being
with a machine but feeling being with
something that could bring something to
our life kind of experience something
that that makes sense in in the way we
live you know and we are talking about
the user that could be they are not like
PhD in robotic they are grandma kids
nurses direct worker so the the the
point is how could they understand the
way it works and and and how could we
match the uh imaginary and the uh
expectation that they could have.
Hopefully we have done thousand of robot
in the past uh and and we met thousand
of of client who ask crazy things on on
the robot and we tried to combine that
into this uh uh this robot and you can
meet him is there there's two version
like Miroa and Miroi the the boy and the
girl and they have 20 cm here they do
not pretend to be a human because if we
do so people expect much more than what
the device can really do but If we
present that as a as a more an animal
like kind of robot, you do not
overestimate what this robot can do. And
then there is a positive surprise that
is coming with with this. So today we
are accumulating uh 400,000
minutes of usage.
So it's which represent a lot of days
that you count. Um and uh we have um uh
produced uh uh more than uh 70 uh units
and we are about to produce hundreds of
them.
>> Wow. Thank you so much. Um wonderful. So
you are coming from different
backgrounds from academia from industry
and we know with the robotics at the
beginning people are very impressed and
they want to understand how it's built
how it works. So I want to understand
from your points of view when did it
come from impressed to actually
experiencing acceptance with the robots
that you are building or the robots that
you are researching? So Morgan have you
had any experiences where you were
looking into the acceptance se segment
of the human robot interaction with
familiars? Yeah. So I we're uh a lot of
what Jerome said I think is important
which is this idea of setting
expectations at a level that you can
then exceed. Um because uh I think
[sighs and gasps] it's it's a uh this is
this is a challenge I think we see
across uh all sorts of technology but
especially um one of the dangers of uh
of using large language models is that
the when you start uh having a
conversation with something and it feels
very human then when it starts going off
the rails when it starts behaving badly
then it's very frustrating. I've said
some terrible things to my Alexa. Um
because it sounds so much like a person
that when it stops listening to me, I
get very, you know, I get very angry. Um
and so, you know, a lot of our design
has been about trying to make something
that's far enough away from something
that you're familiar with that when it
behaves intelligently, when it behaves
in a lifelike way, it feels like a
pleasant surprise and you're not
expecting it to do more than it can. And
so that's a really important design
challenge which you know we have a first
uh prototype of and we're starting now
to put into into contact with users.
We've done multiple studies and uh we
think we're in the right area but it's
definitely a place where we're putting a
lot of attention to see if we get it
just right.
>> Great. Thank you Jerome.
>> Yes. So so we are deploying robots. So
we have a lot of situation where people
react to the presence of the robot. But
first I would like to say that accept
acceptance should not be a goal. It
should be um I mean if you do that it's
like if you try to manipulate people and
make them accept something you know if
you want to to create a design that
makes sense you have to come with the
hurt and trying to to make something
that that comes with some beautiful
interaction and that is that should be
the the goal not manipulation you know
with acceptance and and we got a very uh
amazing feedback by the user um some
people are uh very happy to to meet
again the the robots I'm crying to so
happy to to to to meet it again and we
are doing things like um we are entering
the for the kids who have concert in
south of France uh the the robot is
entering the bunker you know the
radiotherapic room the kid is attached
on the table so it's very traumatic and
they are so afraid about that you know
uh and and and they should be alone
because the parent cannot enter that
room doctors and so the robot is
entering the room with the the kids and
he's not feeling alone anymore and uh
and that's an amazing uh experience and
we got so fantastic feedback that that
make us understand that we cracked
something in in that uh um in the
interaction and and I could add
something on top of that because from
years you know with robots like now
robot or pepper robot I tried to put
life in the robot and and honestly it
was still a puppet uh still you get the
robot here and you do not feel um the
interaction really working and and I
realized later on that that what
[clears throat] the robot should do is
reflecting the people life. They should
feel they exist into the robot eyes and
this is monatory for what you do. This
is absolutely mandatory for what we do
and and it works well today. We have
some concrete proof that people need to
feel they exist into the robot eyes.
That's a simp simple things but that
pretty complex to develop.
Great. Thank you, Georgia.
>> Um I think um what is most important or
what we discovered through the studies
on human robot interaction is that um
there's indeed a way you can manipulate
um your how we perceive the machine. Um
we develop a scale that allows us to
measure how much you believe the robot
has intention. And this concept of
intentionality is very fundamental in
our understanding of the robot as an
agent. Then if you think the robot is an
agent
um yeah at that point you treat the
robot differently. Can be positive or
negative here. It's not a judgment of an
ethical judgment. It's just a fact. Um
the scale correlates with certain
signals in the EG. we can reliably
predict whether you are going to see the
robot as an an agent as a an intentional
agent rather than just a machine uh just
a car just a device. Um I think it's
super interesting because of course
opens also ethical questions uh but um
also allows us to understand really how
we design the robot and if we want to
design robots that interact naturally to
the point that they're um interpreted as
something else more intelligent than
what they are which can be may have pros
and cons depending on the situation. Um
and the other thing is that um for
instance in this scale when you try with
roboticist
um there's no intentionality there
because of course the designers of the
robot have no
um misunderstanding of what the robot is
made of. Um on the other hand um we
found particularly useful to have the
robot interact with children uh
diagnosed with ASD for instance autism.
Um and it works very well in that case
probably for various reasons. It's it's
better to interact with a to with a toy
than a person. Um and it's also um the
robot is very repetitive. There are
various things but the robot is very
effective in um showing the kids how to
behave in certain situation and they
learn a lot from the robot. They don't
learn as much from people. So I mean how
we want to develop these machines is up
to us. But um I I mean there's a
scientific way to measure what is
happening and it's very cool I think
because it tells us a lot about us uh
from the neuroscientific point of view.
That's super interesting. Uh we should
talk about it. Uh because one of the
most like around acceptance most
interesting we've been deploying with
people with dementia was a dementia
group. Um and one thing that was that
stuck with me they kind of intuitively
knew if the robot was alive and
controlled or not. Like they walked to
the robot they knocked the face shell.
It was off at that point and like oh
nobody home. And walked away. Um and
then when it was on and they basically
was interactive with them like despite
some really really strong cases of
dementia they were supernaturally
interacting with it. They were playing
games they were uh you could guide them
and this was sort of the basis that we
then actually used to be able to do a
pilot with a person that has dementia in
their private home. Um and that like she
called it her best friend after a week
and I was and I think that's something
we saw like people very quickly
normalize the robot in the deployment
like day two the latest is kind of
normal to have the thing there and it's
very surprising for us like and I was
also asking them don't you think it's a
bit scary at night when it stands there
and the answer was no actually she feel
protected by it uh so very quickly we
see this kind of normalization and it
comes also with a risk uh so very
quickly people trust the robot too much
and we saw this in deployments. So uh
where one situation was kind of
interestingly it was uh the robot was
making dinner. So at the working at the
fridge and then suddenly on the operator
view you see the hand of the elderly
lady grasping into the door of the of
the fridge taking something out and
walking away. So she assumed this is to
totally safe from a roboticist
perspective. I was very nervous at that
point. I mean we designed the robot safe
and as a soft and swan but this is not
sort of what intent what it was intend
at the end of a pilot she was like ah I
made this cake can you cook can you
slice it with the robot so she took out
this huge knife and was like here give
it to the robot can you slice it like no
I'd rather not and then it was like no
no no but that's look I keep my distance
so now she did it and then of course she
couldn't take her distance and it's I
think that's very something also very
interesting um in the deployments uh
what you discover when you actually have
them in the field and and see people
react to it. Also with dementia like we
can guide the people. We saw this
acceptance very quickly but then also
you thinks like one thing they do is is
she kind of she thinks this is how you
continue and then even though this might
be completely wrong and she then does
that and you kind of need to find a way
to stop them and like okay no this is
actually not how you should do this
task. uh let's go two step back and like
for example we're doing um cupcakes uh
and then in the microwave and sort of
that's a concept you didn't know so
basically cupcake was out she took a
spoon and was stirring it so it was gone
um but again sort of I think that's
really shows people very quickly
normalize on the robot it's there you
get used to it uh and then it's really
also our responsibility to make sure
that within that use case it remains
safe
>> yeah thank you for sharing that it comes
down to the responsibility on the
designers and the builders of this
technology and so you've been sharing
different utility relationship segments.
What about uh the attachment what we've
been seeing right now we are moving from
the economy of uh having so much
presence on social media and digital
medias but right now with the robotics
we are creating this new layer of
relationships in between humans and
machines which can take a form of an
attachment. So I would love to hear from
you from the academic standpoint and
from the industry standpoint how are you
engineering for it and what are some of
the risks and the opportunities that
you're seeing in terms of human machine
attachments.
Um I can start by saying that we're not
doing much in that direction but there's
an element continuing the discussion uh
there's an element that I think is
important and this is a a true
experiment that we've done um you know a
very powerful feeling in humans is
called this sense of agency which means
when we do something to be understand
that there's a consequence and the
consequence relate to what we've done we
press the button the light goes off. Um
there's a way to measure that um whether
we have that feeling. Um for instance,
if you're pressing a button and instead
of pressing yourself um you receive I
don't know a TMS discharge which is a
tool to disturb the the brain and you
press um without willing to press the
button button get pressed you don't get
the same feeling. It's not you
controlling the light to go off. Um now
um there's another thing which is called
the sense of joint agency which is when
you interact with another person and we
can replace the other person with a
robot of course and the thing is that um
you feel part of a joint action and
imagine every day being having that
feeling that the robot is working for
you is doing something for you. Um I
think that
gets to the attachment point because the
robot feels completely as an extension
of your body a bit like another person
will feel. So not completely you but in
a sense you can interact in such a way
that the robot does something for you.
Um and again this relates to
intentionality. So you have the effect
only if you believe the robot is
intentional is an autonomous agent
doesn't work for uh a simple tool. Um
and I think well we getting there we
start to put together all these elements
uh at least from the research standpoint
um from from the scientific point of
view that um if we build things in a
certain way then um you get even
attached to the robot. Again it raises I
think a very important question that is
ethical in origin. Um shall we do it or
better we stay away from that?
>> I I can jump on on that. Um so that's a
a very important question. So as a robot
designer we should ask ourself um what
is this um what is the mission? What do
we want to bring to the people? Do we
want to bring them a slave that is hiden
near the the wallet and and acting
during the night with no face with no
interaction with just doing something
because we want that to be done or and
and and what is the limit of the
knowledge of that? What is the um the
the reality of this? Is that a actual
real being or is that something else? I
think we should answer that question as
designer of humanoid robot and the way I
I decided to to to address that point is
is uh accepting that there's machine are
uh designed by human like like in the
movie like in the video game like
everywhere. So in the movie, in the
video game, you have to define the
story. You have to make people
understand that this is a story. When
you go to the movie, this is not an
actual real situation. That's just a
movie. So here, that's just a robot, a
character from a story that believe this
body is in the story, you know, trying
to that's an ethical point of view. I
don't want user to believe that this is
an actual real being with a fully
autonomous way of thinking things. Uh
because I'm designing that, we are
designing this. We are putting into that
robot the the barriers, the trust, the
knowledge. So we are making a choice. Uh
in French we say editorialization.
It's editorial editorialized
uh choice, you know. uh and and we are
all doing that and we should not lie
this is what we do and in order to make
things understandable for the user the
story has always be uh a way to do that
and I think what what is true about that
for the human robot is also true for an
AI what is the limit do they have an
opinion in politics do they I don't know
uh have a bias on on the world so we
should define much more uh that kind of
things and and um the way we designed It
is um you know a robot have a strong
limitation. The robot is only in the
place where the robot is. So could we
define the story where the um character
have an opportunity to use that body but
can also use your phone or your use a
screen or uh web or whatever. So in the
story we um use the ID of a character
living in a far far away planet that
find a way to communicate with us and
sometime you can use electronic device
like a phone like a like a computer
which allow many more people to have a
good experience with the character
itself.
>> U yeah I mean this is a crazy important
question. Um, I think uh to to some
extent there's nothing wrong with
forming an attachment to something
that's inanimate or that isn't human. We
form I mean I have very attached to
several of my books in my library. I'm
very attached to uh even attached to
things that pretend to be people like
the the characters in uh you know in
Star Wars or something like that. The
those are all things I form attachments
to but I do understand at a fundamental
level kind of what the relationship is.
I think that's the important thing we
have to do because I I think many of us
can relate to having loved somebody who
didn't love you back and maybe taking a
while to figure that out. It can feel
good at the beginning and then at the
end it feels very bad. And I think we
want to make sure that we don't produce
that experience where uh what we want is
sort of the
there is ultimately I think an intent as
designers that we put things out in the
world because we care about people and
that we do want people to have positive
experiences. So there's a reality of
care behind the design, but there's also
a reality of limitations of how that
care can be expressed through
technology. And so I think that it's
easy for people to form attachments.
We're wonderful at forming attachments.
And one of the main jobs that we have is
to give people the information that will
make that attachment fulfilling and
helpful and and uplifting and not
ultimately dissatisfying or or
manipulative. Yeah, it's not an easy
question. Yeah, maybe I think one thing
we haven't talked yet that I would like
to add in terms of attachment is I think
there's more than one type of
attachment. One comes from this kind of
emotional and social attachment.
Something that like you're building kind
of a friendship and then the other comes
from the basically utility you draw from
the system. Um like if we help a person
live independently, if we give elderly
back sort of some freedom, that's also
some attachment. And um what we saw is
also like they kind of be traded for
each other to some extent as well and
they can like influence each other as
well. And the sort of that's sort of one
thing we try to leverage is basically f
create both types of attachment to some
extent um to be really robust and then
also uh maybe compensate of some of the
utility of the like that sort of
developing itself. Like the robots right
now we have they're not great yet
honestly. uh they can't do proper
cooking and whatever they cook is kind
of well it's not a four-star uh menu. Uh
so we really we can use the other form
of attachment and turning it into
someone you work with instead of who
works for you and use that then to cover
up some of the shortcomings of the
robots to some [snorts] extent and that
works really well in practice what we
saw.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Very very
interesting insights. Um I want to take
us a little bit to the future. Let's
imagine uh five years from now and uh
humans and machines are living in
harmony. What would be some of the
design decisions that you think are
going to be very obvious that we did
wrong at the beginnings? Like there's a
lot of conversations about the form
about does it need legs? Does it need
ears? What does it actually for which
purpose? So I would love to take a
little bit of a future guess from you.
What do you think are going to be some
design decisions that we made wrong or
that we are about to make right?
>> I I think we'll find that uh motion is
way more important than we thought to
and you see this also like in the
animatronics that like the way it moves
is so important and I think it will turn
out that how it looks actually is less
important than we think.
Uh, I think maybe the biggest thing that
I see is doesn't feel like a a long-term
thing that will that will survive is the
this feeling of convergence onto right
now there's a lot of convergence onto a
form. A lot of the robots out there kind
of look the same their human plan and I
feel like uh I don't know of a I don't I
think life tends to be divergent. I
think that good innovation tends to be
divergent and I feel like the idea that
everything will be solved by a single
form factor is a very uh I think it's a
a nice early idea but I don't think it
will stand the test of time. I think the
divergence of forms uh to the different
functions and the different ways that
are going to help our lives is going to
be the thing that will ultimately win
out.
Uh yeah so that's a very difficult
question because we have to understand
what what is going to to happen. Um from
my point of view the user interaction is
something that is definitively key. So
um the way you touch robot, the way you
move the robot, the way he react when
you do so, the way he look at you, what
how he cooperate with you, um um doing
an action, you ask for and how could you
ask in very intuitive way things that
this robot should do in a very safe way
too. And uh today we have a very uh
spectacular show uh with humanoid robot
doing amazing things and techn
technically it's a really impressive but
uh but at the end uh what will be in the
earth in in in five years it's us it's
my grandma it's my kids it's and there
are the people who will have to face
that kind of technology. So what do we
do for them? How do we design a humanoid
robot? So then is usable by anybody.
>> Um I think it will take more than five
years. But having said that um I think
we'll regret using so much metal and
electric motors and we say why we
haven't thought of different materials.
>> Thank you. Okay. Last question. In one
word, what would you say is one of the
most important factors in human robot
design? What are you factoring for when
you're designing a yoto? But one word,
>> moving eyes, heart,
>> expectations,
eye to eyes.
>> Great. Thank you so much. Really enjoyed
this one. Thank you guys.